okay so super Sons is like God it's the
best thing coming out of DC rebirth
right now this story is amazing and it's
and it's so cool because I love the idea
of of like Jonathan Kent and Damian
Wayne of like Superman's son and
Batman's son teaming up because all they
do in this story is bicker that's it
that's all they do is bicker with each
other and it is amazing it is it is so
cool to see but it also kind of
highlights the strengths and weaknesses
of each of the individual characters and
it does it in a way that it all kind of
comes together and it all creates this
really fun story and that's what makes
super Sun so interesting it's just fun
like it's just good old-fashioned fun
comic book storytelling so initially we
pick up with with John Thinkin on his
way to school and again this is really
just kind of like a reflection of
everyday life which is kind of what you
have to do with super Sons I mean it's
not Justice League right like you can't
uh just have them fighting one group you
know from from story to story you know
the characters in the Justice League are
well established I mean the flash you
know Green Lantern are really the Green
Lanterns uh Simon baz and Jessica Cruz
Superman Batman Wonder Woman so on and
so forth they are all established
characters we don't need to know the
intricacies of their everyday lives
because we have their own solo books for
that but there's no super you know super
boy solo book there's no Damian Wayne
solo book I would read them but there is
no book that's out there right now for
those individual characters actually
you've got to kind of put things into
perspective in a way that it gives us an
idea of what they stand for and super
Sons is a great way to do that now we
know just by virtue of being the son of
Superman and We Know by virtue of the
stories that he's been in both in the
Superman comics and in the action comics
comics kind of a weird phrase that uh
that Jonathan Kent is very much standing
up for the right thing standing up for
people who can't stand up for themselves
doesn't like people being picked on
especially when it comes to snowball
fights and they start throwing snowballs
at people with rocks inside they're
literally just throwing snowball folks
with rocks inside we used to do that
back when I was younger it's kind of a
it's something I'm ashamed to admit but
we used to do that
there was one time I was in high school
I'll never forget there was one time I
was in high school there was this guy
named coach Zuckerman and that guy was a
dick but he was he was the safe teacher
and he was walking it was was walking
into the classroom one or walking into
the lunchroom one day and somebody hit
him in the back of the head with a
snowball
this guy turned around he was so pissed
he was so mad he was absolutely amazing
but uh but anyway so with regards to the
to this story to Super Sons um the cool
thing about this is that we also get the
Ingenuity of Damian Wayne and what we
end up finding out is that Damien Wayne
has not only been masquerading as the
bus driver of the other kids that ride
to school with Jonathan Kent but he's
also been masquerading as a substitute
teacher and that's kind of the crazy
thing right like it's kind of a crazy
scenario and so the funny thing about
this is that we also end up finding out
that they're basically sneaking out now
they're not supposed to be that they're
supposed to be going to bed they're
supposed to be calling it a day but it's
really Jonathan Kent who's kind of
corrupted by the influence of uh of of
Damian Wayne in the sense that
Jonathan's gonna go to bed he's gonna
call it a day he's very wholesome very
grounded a kid that doesn't really break
the rules but Damien Wayne popping up is
basically saying hey look there is an
investigation that's going on that I'm
doing there's been some break-ins you
know I want to go check it out you
should come with me now in truth in
terms of why it is that Damien Wayne
brought Jonathan Kent we don't know and
in fact we don't find out but I would
surmise as smart as Damon and Wayne is
he is toying with the idea of
potentially enrolling Jonathan Ken into
the Teen Titans which by the way if
Jonathan can't joined the Teen Titans it
would be amazing uh it'd be it'd make
that book just so much more interesting
I mean it's already amazing it didn't
make it even better um but why don't you
talk a little bit more about that as we
get to this story because that's kind of
what ends up happening but the two of
them basically sneak out and it's kind
of funny because Jonathan doesn't want
to like he doesn't want to sneak out of
his house but of course Damien gets him
to do it and they end up traveling over
to lexcorp now this is one of the cool
things about the story this is one of
the things that I love so much is tomasi
treats the superhero Community as a
family in a lot of ways right I mean the
Justice League are very much a family
and like well the suicide squad is as
close to a family as you can get when
you have a bomb planet in your head and
Amanda Waller's threatening to blow it
up and kill you if you don't do what she
tells you to so I guess they're kind of
a family to a degree but in terms of how
tomasi puts everything together all the
superheroes are more or less a family
and that's what we would expect right I
mean we would expect it to play out that
way they have their own issues they have
their own groups you've got Batman's you
know Justice League of America you've
got the Justice League you know we'll
probably have the Justice Society
somewhere along the line and that was
even a big Mantra under Jeff Johns you
know the Justice League is a strike
force the Justice Society as a family
the idea is that if it really hits the
fan all the superheroes will be there
for one another and the way that he
plays on this is with the introduction
of Lex Luthor as Superman remember
during the last days of Superman or I
guess following the final days of
Superman the death of the New 52
Superman the new 52 Lex Luthor stood up
and took his place as Superman in his
mind when the classic Superman showed up
he was considered to be a false Superman
you know likely they looked at him and
said no he's not the Superman that I've
known for all these years the New 52
Superman is the one that I know he's the
one that's dead I'm going to carry on as
mantle again this all hearkens back to
Forever Evil it all hearkens back to
that story that transitioned Lex Luthor
from being a bad guy to being a good guy
and so because of that one of the funny
things that happens here is when he
encounters uh Jonathan Ken and Damian
Wayne his his question is like it's a
school night why are you guys here now
of course the funny thing is keep in
mind Lex does not know the truth about
Damien or uh or Jonathan you know as far
as he's aware they're just a couple of
kids here now I haven't read that far
into like forever evil and I haven't
paid that much attention to uh to to Lex
Luthor but I would have to believe that
somewhere along the line he became aware
of Damian Wayne and who Damien Wayne is
so at the very least he probably knows
you know who the character of Damien is
but he may not know that Damien is Robin
I mean again tomasi kind of plays it
fast and loose and it's fine I mean it
works for what it is it doesn't create
massive continuity errors or anything
like that you know it just kind of asked
a couple questions here and there with
regards to the story and for me that's
one of the things that kind of Keeps The
Narrative going is the idea of asking
questions poking around a bit kind of
saying hey look is this where this fits
in or is that where this fits in or
something along those lines you know
it's just one of those those cool
scenarios when it comes to storytelling
but uh suffice it to say what is up
happening here is Damian Wayne basically
uses Superboy as a distraction and again
this is really really cool because
essentially because you know Jonathan
can't fly yet and so he basically kind
of knocks John and they can't off the
building Lex Luthor has to rescue him
and in the interim Damian Wayne goes
into Lex Corp and starts poking around
now again this is the cool thing about
Damien because Damien is in a lot lot of
ways just as capable as Batman and
that's really the Crux of this story
that's the Crux of his narrative
throughout DC rebirth if you're reading
you know about a Detective Comics if
you're reading Batman if you're reading
Nightwing you know if you're reading
super Sons the idea is that Damien Wayne
is trying to prove that he should be the
successor to the Batman mantle once
Bruce Wayne retires that's his whole
stance and that's something that DC is
kind of teasing with that's something
that Tom King you know that the tinian
that's something that DC as a whole is
is teasing with and kind of toying with
following the events of the button right
remember I mean if you remember if you
saw our video on the button you'll find
it down in the description Batman Bruce
Wayne had talked to his father Thomas
Wayne from a different universe and
Thomas Wayne said stop being Batman Gobi
Bruce Wayne raise your son have a life
and the implication was that at the end
of the button that Bruce Wayne was not
going to be Batman anymore which begs
the question if that's the case who's
going to take over the role now we know
he's grooming like Duke for something in
particular Duke of course is the
character who's largely prominent in an
All-Star Batman uh but the fact remains
here the possibility is there that
Damian Wayne could take over the mantle
and if I'm gonna be honest with you guys
I think he's the best person suited for
it if I were going to pick a person who
is going to take over the Batman mantle
once Bruce Wayne leaves I would pick
Damien Wayne any day of the week dick
Grayson's already been Batman Tim Drake
is dead as far as Batman and all those
guys are concerned you've already got
Barbara Gordon bad girl you've already
got Kate Kane or whatever it is uh uh
Batwoman you've already got a Litany of
characters who were solidified in their
own roles the last remaining Robin is
Damian Wayne give it to him that's my
stance I'm curious what's your all
stance on that who would you make the
next Batman if Bruce Wayne retires who
would you put in that position but the
fact remains here that once likes Luther
tracks down Damien and begins to
question him uh Damien Wayne just really
kind of toys with the idea that he's got
bombs planted all throughout the uh the
private laboratory of Lex Luthor in his
own lexical building now of course using
this as a distraction Damien and
Superboy effectively just bail out and
so we actually won't see Lex Luthor for
a little while instead what we find out
is that the real goal of Damian Wayne
here was to basically download the uh
the complete Security log of lexcorp
basically going through and looking at
all the video footage now again this is
one of the reasons why why Damian is so
smart and it's one of the reasons why he
is so capable because Lex Luthor one of
the smartest men in the world did not
realize that Damian Wayne had hacked
into his system he didn't realize that
all he knew was that Damian Wayne just
some kid had gone through and planted a
whole bunch of bombs now again this is
also Damian Wayne using the fact that
Lex Luthor doesn't know who he is if Lex
Luthor had known who Damian Wayne was
there was probably a really good chance
he would have approached the situation
differently I mean the Son of Batman
Batman's one of the smartest men if not
the smartest man in the DC Universe it
would have made sense that he would have
treated Damien Wayne with the same kind
of respect with regards to his intellect
but regardless of how this event played
out the fact remains here that Damian
Wayne going through the footage of the
security logs basically ends up
realizing that there is a kid who broke
into the uh the laboratory of Lex Luthor
and basically stole something called the
Amazo armor now we'll get to that here
in a second because Amazo is a really
cool Concept in DC it's one of the
coolest things they've done for quite
some time especially during Jeff John's
run of Justice League but the fact
remains here that going through and
looking at the video footage between
Damian Wayne's interlocked his resources
and and superboy's abilities what they
end up finding out is that this kid is
somebody by the name of Reggie so of
course jumping on the robin motorcycle
because you know as Damian why wouldn't
he have a robin motorcycle they trace
the location of Reggie back to a
warehouse only to find that the
warehouse is basically just filled with
the dead bodies of what looks like
Reggie's family so this story kind of
borderlines on the idea of things being
somewhat Dark and Dangerous while also
maintaining kind of the the fun vibrant
Edge that makes super Sun so cool now
that's one of the interesting things
about this where Jonathan basically says
look I can't deal with this these are
dead bodies these are Beyond me you know
I gotta go we need to call Batman
Superman let the adults handle this and
Damian Wayne says no we have to stay
behind and investigate and the two
effectively part ways Jonathan comes
across a little girl in the woods but
both Jonathan and Damian are basically
attacked by their opposite fathers you
know or at least set upon by their
opposite fathers uh Superman and Batman
now of course what we find out here is
that these are essentially Androids
these are not actually Batman and
Superman the fact remains here that we
end up having you know of course Damien
and Superboy you know taking on their
fathers respectively and that kind of a
thing but uh both of these Androids are
essentially deactivated by this young
girl and this is when we start to get
the backstory of everything that's
essentially going on here and this is
when we start to get into the idea of
the Amazon virus now within the realm of
DC Comics the Amazo concept comes in two
forms there's the Amazo Android and then
there's the Amazon virus the Amazo
Android was pretty straightforward it
was basically developed by a guy named
Professor Ivo and the Amazo Android had
the ability to duplicate the powers of
the Justice League it's simply just like
had all their powers so as was explained
here in uh in super Suns is exactly how
it was for the most part Amazon was a
one-man Justice League that flashes
speed Superman's strength you know so on
and so forth with regards to the
different powers that existed with
regards to the Justice League now the
Amazo virus was something that was
actually designed by Lex Luthor for the
purpose of neutralizing the powers of
many humans who were deemed to be too
dangerous the problem was that according
to virtually every form of every
governing body in existence for the most
part it was deemed to be too extreme it
was deemed to be cruel and unusual
punishment and so in response it was
more or less shelved I mean it was used
a couple times but nothing ever really
came of it until a guy by the name of
Nathaniel Tyran I think it is I'm not
gonna swear to his last name but he had
basically been tasked with killing Lex
Luthor screwed it up and then
accidentally released the amazovirus and
so what the amazovirus did is it
basically began bonding itself to hosts
and giving people Powers you know if I
kind of had to make like a comparison we
could go with like the amazovirus kind
of being like the equivalent of the
terrigen myth so to speak the difference
is that you didn't you know you don't
have to have a pre-existing Gene in
order to be given Powers because of the
amazing meso virus the amazovirus just
gives you abilities now what these
abilities were just depended on people I
mean different people just manifested
different abilities arbitrarily there
was no guessing what a person's Powers
were going to be you couldn't look at a
person's age and weight and height and
so on and so forth and say well that
person is probably going to have
telepathy it's just whatever power they
happen to get now for the most part
after a while the power assembly just
began to dissipate people began to lose
them but there were some individuals who
kept them and the family of Reggie is
one of the families that kept those
Powers the issue with this is that for
the most part their powers were largely
self-contained they were largely
isolated to themselves meaning that they
had like super strength or they could
fly or something like that in the case
of Reggie he could duplicate himself and
whenever he duplicated himself each
duplicate had the same ability as all
the other versions so they were all
equals it wasn't like when he duplicated
himself his power began to decrease with
each duplicate so it's not like you know
he had two versions of himself and each
one had 50 percent of the total power it
was you know he duplicate himself and
each one of them have 100 of his total
power the problem with this was that
Reggie began to go awry and began to
effectively lose his mind and so what he
did is he actually started creating
these uh robotic duplicates of his
family and then just started routinely
killing his family all the time but the
more he began to devolve into the realm
of insanity the more he began to go
about stealing like a meso armor in a
maso tech and different things like that
and so what this did is it allowed him
to duplicate locate himself and then
using the Amazo armor allow him to
duplicate the powers of anybody that he
comes into contact with now that's a big
difference here he's almost like Protege
from Marvel Comics you know Protege had
the ability to duplicate the powers of
anybody as long as he saw them using
their powers anyone from a person with
super strength all the way up to the
Living Tribunal he could just copy
whatever their abilities were reality
warping telepathy Telekinesis the whole
nine yards with Reggie he has to be
within the vicinity of a person in order
to duplicate their power so it's really
more passive than anything else he
doesn't have to see super boy flying he
doesn't have to see Superboy using super
strength he just has to be around him
and then the Amazo suit will just
automatically duplicate those powers and
allow Reggie to use them now the reason
why this is so cool and the reason why
it matters so much is because this
presents a legitimate incredible threat
to the world that his super sons are
going to be dealing with and that's why
this is cool is because it would have
been very easy for tomasi to just kind
of pawn it off and it'd be like your
super Sons vol 1 and they're gonna stop
a bank robbery I mean it was entirely
possible that he could have done that it
would have draw Down The Narrative of
the story and it wouldn't have been
nearly as good as it is right now
instead he gave us a kid that has the
ability to duplicate himself and then
took the Amazo armor and now has all
these duplicates running around that
have the ability to copy the powers of
others and effectively create a super
powered Army for himself and so because
of this what we also learn is that this
sister because she's basically a robot
she still has the Amazo powers of
herself of her normal human counterpart
meaning she has the ability to control
machinery and so for the most part these
you know robotic forces of Reggie are
pretty much taken out pretty fast I mean
it's not a great big huge ordeal but
they're taken out pretty quickly and of
course this results in a Damian Wayne
and Superboy basically taking off now of
course along the way while they're
trying to find Reggie of course what we
end up having is Damian Wayne just kind
of hijacking one of the cyborgs meddling
with his helmet but we don't really find
out what it is that they're doing
instead we still get like all these
references from Superboy Jonathan Ken
talking about the Teen Titans and
different things like that and that's
one of the funny things is because one
of the big questions people had when
super sons was essentially launched and
when and Jonathan Kent was introduced as
the son of Superman in the modern day
the question was why is he not on the
Teen Titans well the answer that's given
is by Damian Wayne is that Jonathan
Kim's just not old enough it's the Teen
Titans not the pre-teen Titans and so
once once Jonathan hits like 13 or 14
years old then he'll probably be
inducted onto the team just because
Damian would be foolish not to have the
son of Superman on the Teen Titans it
seems like a stunt that he would pull
but he'd be foolish to not do that and
so of course with the two of them being
captured by Kid Amazo simply because of
the fact that the powers of Jonathan
come and go because he doesn't have full
control of his faculties yet uh this
inevitably leads to basically kid Amazo
just kind of dumping the whole plan and
talking about everything that he's doing
and his goal to basically take over the
world but that's why this is so cool is
because with an army of robots that can
duplicate the powers of everybody that
they come across he could conceivably do
that he could literally take out the
Justice League and take out the Green
Lanterns if they arrived on Earth and
could actually conquer the world this is
why tomasi is out the way that he
basically ends this story is done so
well the reason this happens is because
of the fact that the robot spots can
only copy organic Powers you know
legitimate Powers meaning powers that
are inherently natural to a person or
powers that are bestowed on a person
with Lex Luthor it's not that way Lex
Luthor Superman's suit is not designed
using you know Superman's genes it's not
designed using you know Kryptonian DNA
it's basically just a technological suit
it's a machinery and that's why it works
is because what we end up having is Lex
Luthor arriving onto the scene after
Damien Wayne had used that helmet to
send Lex a message and saying here is
the kid who's been breaking into Lex
Corp come and get him and defeat this
guy this kid is not able to duplicate
the powers of Lex Luthor because Lex
Luthor has no powers he's simply just
using a mechanized suit if he had
brought in you know Superman then
suddenly we would have these Amazo
robots with the full power of Superman
and Superman would easily be defeated
when five or six of them maybe even 10
or 11 of them team up on him and that
would be the end of that the super Sons
would probably be killed and then the
world would just be right for the
picking from uh from from kid Amazo so
again it's really really good thinking
I'll be happy of tomasi in order to give
this story a legitimate out now of
course while Lex Luthor is dealing with
the forces of kid Amazo and kitamezo
himself Jonathan and Damian you know get
the girl and her family out of there and
they really just kind of call it a day I
mean you know you end up having kid
Amazo who's ultimately defeated once he
begins recalling all these versions into
himself and the reason why he's defeated
is because of the fact that his sister
uses her control over Machinery to force
the Amazo armor off of kid Amazo and so
from here Reggie basically just kind of
begins to break down and lose his mind
now the explanation that's given here by
tamasi is that Reggie's just been
splitting himself time and time again
the more he split himself the more
unstable he became and the more he
stress his body's physical structure now
that actually makes sense that is an
explanation that makes sense within the
context of this story and the reason why
is because there's a Litany of
superheroes all across the realm of
comics who can duplicate themselves
that's not new and none of them really
go insane by virtue of duplicating
themselves but that's because they have
training they've been doing it for some
real measure of time with Reggie he
doesn't have 4 formal training he has
whatever you know whatever times he's
been doing it but he's kind of pushing
himself too hard too fast and because of
that his body does not know how to
handle the experience of being stretched
into so many verses of himself in such
an extreme way instead it's almost like
a rubber band eventually it'll just snap
back and when it does his mind will go
with it so Reggie isn't really killed so
much as he's just incapacitated and
that's really the end of that you know
while Lex Luthor is kind of talking to
this young girl and saying look we'll
find you a home we'll find you a place
to stay and we'll get you on the road to
becoming a legitimate superhero given
your ability to control Machinery Damian
Wayne and Jonathan Kent bail out they
take off
they go home and it's really kind of
funny because once they get back to
Jonathan Kent's house they have to deal
with the most formidable enemy which is
a very angry mom so
so there's like two kinds of comic books
in the world right like comic books that
are good and then there's Comics that
are like the best thing coming out of DC
rebirth and super Sons is one of those
God I love this story so much
super Sons is so fun because it's just
like this question that was asked what
if we created a story where we have a
couple of like kids with superpowers
just goofing off yeah man let's write
that story or where to begin in college
super Sons
so the cool thing about this is remember
superson's focuses heavily on Damien
Wayne the biological son of Bruce Wayne
and Jonathan Kent the biological son of
Superman and it's cool because over the
course of their publication history we
see Superman and Batman friends we've
seen them enemies we've seen them in
almost every scenario in terms of how
friends relate to each other and so it
makes sense that if the two of them were
gonna have sons their sons would follow
the exact same path and that's the cool
thing about this because while the
writing is better than it was back in
the 1940s and 1950s and 60s in a lot of
different ways what you guys are reading
right now is basically what we we saw in
the early stories way back in you know
before crisis unoffended us with Batman
and Superman we saw some bickering but
for the most part they always got along
again this story comes from the
aftermath of the first Super Sons video
we did which basically saw them taking
on kid Amazo which was a guy who
basically began going through and
duplicating the powers of other Heroes
and then using them with the intention
of world domination now of course it was
a little kid and it was largely just
Superman and Batman's abilities and
powers that were being copied and that
was really about it but in this instance
because of the fact that Damien Wayne
had basically grabbed Jonathan Kent and
took him on the adventure when it was
all said and done they were both
grounded because they're both kids and
they both basically snuck out this is
the immediate aftermath to all that in
the sense of Damian Wayne is basically
grounded now the other half of this is
that so is Jonathan Kent but he's
grounded away from being able to use his
powers now I'll be honest with you guys
Jonathan Kent is like my favorite
character in DC right now he is
hilarious like I absolutely love his
whole thing because he's so young and
vibrant and like brings a friend fresh
perspective to comics and that's the
cool thing about him in in DC is because
for a lot of teenagers they went through
the same thing that he did right like
you go through here you look at this
whole Jonathan Kent thing and a lot of
teenagers went through the same
situation I mean remember you know he's
basically in his pre-teen years he's not
quite a teenager yet but he's
approaching that point in his life when
he wants Independence when he wants to
be able to go out and form his own
little niche in the world now he's not
experienced enough he doesn't have the
wherewithal to know the kind of dangers
that are out there but that's the give
and take that comes with being a
teenager it's you basically battling
against your parents and so in this case
of Jonathan Kent the biggest issue that
he has is that Lois Lane and Superman
are wanting to move back to Metropolis
now remember in DC rebirth when it came
to Action Comics and the Superman comics
basically two stories both detailing the
life of uh of Superman and his uh his
supporting characters while they were
telling two different events the common
theme between Action Comics and Superman
is that it dealt with the idea of
wrapping up all loose ends I dealt with
the idea of removing the new 52 Lois
Lane it dealt with the idea idea of
removing the New 52 Superman and taking
classic Lois Lane and classic Superman
and putting them in their place and so
what this has basically happened what
has really come to at the time this
story is being written and especially
when it comes to Superman comics is that
it basically focuses on this idea that
they are now in their positions they're
now in their roles and DC is taking the
next logical step which is to move them
to Metropolis the problem with this is
like any kid in that scenario Jonathan
doesn't like change now that's a Common
Thread when it comes to like just human
beings in general right like we get used
to things being a certain way we get
accustomed to things being a certain way
and we don't like it when they change
and so in this instance Jonathan knows
the life that he lives he knows the
friends that he has he knows the
environment of Hamilton County he does
not want to move away from that lose the
life that he's built on the auspices
that he has to go move forward move to
Metropolis and start a life of new the
other half of this is that again he's
growing into becoming this angsty kid
challenging barriers and so because of
the fact that he'd been grounded from
using his powers he lashes out and
simply saying well you guys just want to
take everything that I love and care
about and you guys want to move me to a
town that I don't know anything about
hiding me away from the world it's all
this frustration all this irritation all
this young angstiness just coming to
bear and him just lashing out into the
world and so because of this because of
the fact that he looks at his current
predicament as basically being a
byproduct of Damian Wayne grabbing him
and then taking him into this conflict
against meso he does what any young kid
that doesn't really know what's going on
he does exactly what they would do and
he just goes after Damian Wayne now this
is cool because this is really kind of
like this toned down comedic but still
somewhat having ties to the battles of
Superman and Batman now of course much
like the Batman Superman stories this
follows the exact same way in the sense
they basically fight one another but
it's a fight to astounding now in truth
this is all just about inexperience I
mean Damian Wayne is very very capable
in what he can do but Jonathan Kent is
not but what Jonathan Kent lacks an
experience he makes up for in durability
and speed and strength so on and so
forth and so again what ends up
happening here is with the two of them
trying to beat the crap out of one
another
and not doing a very good job the whole
conflict is suddenly stopped by Alfred
Alfred basically walks in and he's like
what in the world is going on here now
of course this leads to Damian Wayne
having this genius idea of crawling into
a hatch this is basically in the well
there's no other way to say it basically
in the anus of the giant dinosaur inside
the bat cave and of course Alfred calls
him out and tells him to get out of that
thing now the cool thing about this is
Alfred basically hits back home and all
the really the progression of Superman
and Batman and that's really where the
meat and potatoes of the discussion in
this video really resides here when it
comes to Batman and Superman and we've
talked about this a million times before
back when DC first made them there was
no shared Universe you just had Batman
stories you had Superman stories and
that was it they never crossed over they
never met there was really no reason to
it wasn't until Superman issue number 75
the Batman and Superman met one another
and when they did it opened up this
whole new world because fans of Batman
and fans of Superman were like oh my God
they're meeting each other and it was
like the coolest thing ever because that
gave rise to stories if their friends
then what would happen if they team up
what kind of stories could we get after
that that's exactly what DC started
doing all the world's finest stories
things like that the Crossovers that
happened later on down the line the idea
here is that Alfred really makes the
case that over the years the two of them
have fought quite a bit they really just
lashed out at each other time and time
again but that's because it took time
for them to trust one another it took
time for that friendship to fully
Blossom it took time for Batman to say
there's like two people in this world
that I trust one's Alfred and one
Superman there have been instances over
the course of their publication history
when that trust has been questioned in a
multitude of different ways Tower of
Babel is probably one of the first
stories that you're thinking about right
now when Batman's database on how to
defeat each member of the Justice League
was thrown into the Limelight when razog
will stole that information and used it
against the Justice League Batman
basically had to stand before the league
and say Raza rule got the got that
information because I assembled it and
put it in a bad case in case any of you
guys went crazy I didn't trust you
enough to believe that you would stay
sane I believed that if you guys went
nuts there'd have to be a way to take
you down out that in and of itself is
not a bad thing the fact that he hid it
from the Justice League is what made
them question his loyalties but again
this really brings him to the sharp
relief the whole Batman Superman fight
and different things like that now to be
honest with you guys I never bought into
the idea that Batman could beat Superman
not a chance it's Superman the guy was
pulling planets out of a Dying Galaxy
just because DC wanted to show that he
had nothing else to do that was like the
first few panels of a story and then the
actual story happened I mean sure you
know there's been stories where Batman
beats Superman but like if we sat down
for a second and we were like I mean who
would really win that fight would be one
page long and it would be Batman saying
something to piss Superman off and
Superman would grab Batman and throw him
into the Sun or maybe he doesn't throw
him into the Sun so maybe Superman takes
him all the way out to the edge of the
explored Universe drops him off and then
comes back to Earth hey Batman just like
paddle really hard maybe you'll make it
back in like 500 million years I have no
idea seriously let's just say this
Batman cannot beat Superman Mr Sunday
movies has amazing video where he's like
Superman could just like kick his head
off or like break his neck or use heat
vision to heat his face up and then make
his make his brain overheat anyway that
whole issue aside the funny thing about
this is that when it comes to Jonathan
in terms of how he relates to his
current situation the idea is that
Superman really sits down and says okay
maybe we were wrong for keeping your
powers in check maybe we were wrong for
basically kind of hindering this ability
because remember the Superman's moral
compass derives from a combination of
what he learned from the Kents but also
the idea that he had to come to grips
with his powers how is he going to use
those powers and that's how it is for
Jonathan Kim despite Lois and Superman
trying to treat their son like he's a
normal kid he's not a normal kid he's a
kid with Incredible abilities and so if
they're going to raise him to become a
productive member of society his powers
have to be a part of that they have to
be part of that equation and so that's
what this turns into it really turns
into Superman basically saying okay I
gotta pitch this to Lois I gotta get my
wife to agree what is basically simply
saying Jonathan is going to forge his
own path in the world this also seems to
him that the idea that Jonathan will be
inducted into the Teen Titans now of
course this came out before the Teen
Titans issue of the whole thing with
Jonathan and Damian and so on and so
forth but it's a cool little One-Shot
it's a fun little story just this idea
that Jonathan is really just kind of
growing into his own stepping out and
becoming more of a hero as opposed to a
kid who just kind of hung around his dad
and watched his dad do some cool things
oh man guys we're finally here and we
really needed it like we really really
needed this because I think it only made
sense right I mean when you look at like
DC Comics you know you got Batman and
Superman they're like the one-two punch
of like the comic book world not just DC
but like the comic book world I mean
there's Batman and Superman and then
there's everybody else you know they go
in hierarchies after that but they'll
stand the test of time as the two most
popular and over the years of their
Publications we've seen them as friends
we've seen them fight you know we've
seen uneasy alliances we've seen strong
friendships that have lasted Generations
we've seen all different kinds of things
with their characters but we've never
really seen an instance like this where
their sons became friends you know where
their sons would go on to carry on the
mantle or at least be the first steps in
carrying on the mantle of their fathers
now with regards to this story uh what
we initially do here is we pick up with
Jonathan Kent now keep in mind one of
the funny things about his character
this is one of the things I like about
him so much is despite the powers that
he will one day possess and despite the
power I guess The Godly level abilities
that he will one day inherit at this
moment right now he's still just kid and
so he has all the same thoughts as kids
he'd use the world like a kid does and
that was the basis behind him being
raised the way he was by Superman it
would have been very easy for Superman
and Lois Lane to tell him oh you're
going to be a God one day and you're
gonna be wildly powerful and for him to
allow that to go to his head and view
himself as somebody who's going to be
you know this dictator grandiose kind of
person but instead they they kept him
down to earth they were like you do not
use your superpowers your super speed to
carry groceries in the house you carry
them in just like everybody else you're
gonna do chores you're gonna do all
these things that kids do so they would
give him a strong work ethic that would
give him a strong understanding of what
it means to be a contributing member of
society one of the other ways this shows
itself is with some kid that's giving
him a hard time now this kid's not
wildly important but what is important
is how Jonathan deals with him but this
kid being a bully he's probably a bully
because his life sucks that's usually
what happens with most bullies their
lives are really bad and they just kind
of express it outward by being angry but
Jonathan could have easily just killed
this kid I mean he could just punched
his head off I mean he could have killed
him in any one of a thousand ways but
instead he's just like I'm not going to
worry about him I'm gonna ignore him
because that's what you're that's what
he was taught to do that's what a normal
human being does you ignore those people
who are bullies you kind of blow them
off let them you know deal with their
own misery and whatever happens to him
happens to him you know you go on with
your life you continue on with your life
and you enjoy how great your life is and
that's what Jonathan was taught to do
but the other half of this is that once
he leaves the school he runs into a girl
named Maya Dakar now my discard is a
character that came out of the whole
Robinson of Superman slash Batman and
Robin line of stories as part of the new
52 and those stories dealt with you know
the the expansion of Damien Wayne and
The New 52 line of stories that dealt
with the backstory of his character in
the new 52. it dealt with you know him
being raised by his mother as an
assassin the year of blood when he was
killing people in his attempts to make
up for all that but during these line of
stories there was a guy named Morgan
Deckard and Morgan Ducard was uh he was
almost like Batman if Batman had become
part like if he had followed the
teachings of the League of Assassins in
the sense that Morgan descard had no
problem torturing and killing people for
information this eventually led to him
coming into conflict with Batman and
Damian and Dave eventually killed Morgan
and because of this his daughter Maya
who was you know almost every ounce and
assassin as he was swore a vendetta
against Damian Wayne but what happened
is in her attempts to track him down and
to kill him she basically became this
former villain's now Ally where she
basically Works alongside Damian Wayne
and in fact her being here is at the
request of Damien this is actually
what's kind of interesting is because as
the two of them get together you know as
the two of them spend time talking to
one another it's really just this kind
of glimpse of a thing it doesn't really
seem to be anything major and eventually
Jonathan and the young girl that he's
with uh leave and then she takes off for
her own thing because she's terrified of
being in this weird like swamp place but
uh the funny thing about this is that
because of the fact that Jonathan is
still very much a kid he's scared of the
same kind of things kids are he really
lets his imagination run away with him
and so we start seeing things and he
starts hallucinating and some of this is
the work of Maya de card but the result
is that Maya basically takes him by
surprise and it seems like she ambushes
him along with Goliath now goliath also
came out of those early stories with
Damien and during the time when he was
tasked to be an assassin he basically
had to go and capture this weird scepter
thing but he had to eliminate all these
beasts that were guarding this scepter
and he chose not to eliminate you know
the smallest of them and the reason why
is because the smallest of them touched
his Humanity it basically made him cry
for a second and because of this he
swore it to take it out of his own and
raise it as his faithful companion more
or less and so Goliath has basically
been there ever since it's really kind
of like a mascot for Damian Wayne and
there are fans out there who love
Goliath who are like Goliath is amazing
because despite not being human and
being able to talk Goliath has a lot of
personality in terms of how it relates
to things it's like the C-3PO of the
Damian Wayne line of stories but the
fact remains here that uh you know my
the card at least seems to initially
take out Jonathan Kent alongside Goliath
and then when Jonathan wakes up he's
being held captive by Damian Wayne and
this is where things get hilarious you
know because Damian's like dude you're a
danger man like you're a dangerous
person you have powers that you don't
really know about him yet you know but
you're going to to manifest those
eventually you don't know how to control
them you killed your cat I mean it's
it's hilarious because you know Damien
and of himself is extremely capable
Damian's very very capable in terms of
his abilities but he's still just a kid
too and that's the cool thing about this
is you know this story puts that into
perspective it reminds us that even
though Damian Wayne's one of the best
assassins in the world you know even
though Jonathan is the son of Superman
in a lot of ways like they're kids
they're they're they're you know young
kids they're young boys and they see the
world in a young way and so what happens
is with Damian Wayne interrogating
Jonathan Kent Batman shows up and he's
like what the hell have you done
and Damien's like well I'm just I'm I'm
interrogating him because he's dangerous
and he's like dude you have no idea what
you've just done and then suddenly
Superman comes barging in now this is
the kicker because Superman's pissed
someone kidnapped his son of course he
was able to find him but his initial
reaction is Batman had his son kidnapped
and so he's he's not Superman angry at
Batman you know because he views him as
a bad guy he's a he's a concerned father
he's an angry father whose son went
missing thing it's like taking Cubs from
Mama Bear you know you just only someone
with a death wish would do something
like that and so of course as soon as
Superman gets here Batman tries to talk
him down he's like hey man look this is
not what you think it is and he's able
to do that but only because of the fact
that Jonathan creates a barrier between
the two of them he's like look you guys
need to chill you guys need to relax and
he gives him some much needed time to
stop you know panicking and it gives
them supposed to be a time to talk but
also because of her stealth abilities
the initial idea of Maya is that No
One's Gonna know she's there but
Superman picks up on her immediately I
mean just because of his hearing and his
seeing and so on and so forth and so
Maya basically has to reveal herself you
know to everybody but in any event the
idea here is that uh Batman you know
while while Jonathan is here they begin
to sort of examine Jonathan and the
reason why is because as we've seen in
the Superman line of comics and even in
the more recent issues of Action Comics
the super boy we're Jonathan Kent's
powers are manifesting but they're
intermittent and so he will have
durability but then he won't you know
he'll have heat vision and then he won't
and the question is why is it because
he's just a growing boy or is it because
there's something going on with him now
on the surface this seems totally
unimportant it seems totally unessential
but it's extremely important because
what this does is it shows us that
Superman's just like any father ever you
know every single parent ever if their
kid comes down with a cough it's oh my
God why is my kid coughing you know is
it because they have a cold or is it
because there's something seriously
wrong parents have an instinct to ensure
their children stay protected even after
their children grow into adults it's
just a parental Instinct it's just a
thing that people do and so for Superman
you know maybe he's overreacting maybe
he's not but the way he's acting is very
much like any father and so it's
basically tomasi telling us yeah
Superman's got these Godly abilities
yeah he can move planets and he spot
dark side and he fought Dooms today all
that kind of stuff and when it comes
down to it he's also a dad he's also
just a dad worried about his son and so
from here we transition to Damien Wayne
and uh and Jonathan and Damian's
basically giving Jonathan you know a
tour around the bad cave and the things
that are there and we get to see bat cow
[Music]
bad cows yeah that cow's amazing I don't
know how many of you guys know about bad
cow but it ran out in front of a car bad
cow
bat cow is awesome but uh but again you
know tomasi just kind of gives us this
rivalry between the two and he actually
has you know Jonathan punch Damian but
it's just kind of this rivalry between
the two more or less you know not really
saying they hate each other so much as
they view each other as Rivals and this
is really kind of cool because Damien
wouldn't consider Jonathan Kent a rival
if Jonathan Kent wasn't somebody worth
worrying about now a lot of what
Jonathan Ken's doing here is just
reactionary to the goating to the
prodding that Damien Wayne is putting
towards him but because Damien knows how
skilled he is in terms of his abilities
because he's trained under the League of
Assassins and because he's trained under
Batman he knows what he's capable of but
the fact that he looks at Jonathan and
sees him as a rival tells us just how
capable Jonathan is as well even if he
doesn't know it and so because of the
fact that the two of them are fighting
amongst each other this is very
indicative of how things were between
you know Batman and Superman when they
first met now every time they meet with
a reboot or anything like that they
always fight one another but then they
always realize they're both going for
the same goal and they end up becoming
Partners sometimes it takes a little
while for them to transition to being
friends sometimes it happens right off
the bat but the fact remains that
there's usually always a conflict
between the two of them but instead of
something allowing you know allowing
these two to work things out with due
time instead what happens is they
basically say look we're gonna put them
through a boot camp we're gonna force
them to work together and either at the
end of all this they're going to come
out as teammates or they're going to
come out as enemies and there's nothing
we can do
and so what we do is we pick up out in
the wilderness out in the middle of
nowhere where they've basically just
been dropped off by uh by Batman and
Superman and they're kind of left to
their own devices Damien Wayne doesn't
have his various uh gadgets with him and
Jonathan's Powers aren't in full
Activation so he doesn't really know how
to use them completely plus he doesn't
have the ability to fly yet and so there
are a lot of drawbacks to him so in a
lot of ways he's just almost as
powerless as Damian Wayne but the other
half of this is it's not as though
Batman and Superman abandoned them not
at all you know you got Superman in the
sky watching everything happen as
they're making their way toward these
three challenges they're supposed to
undergo but you've also got Batman who's
watching these events unfold as well and
so you know they they haven't left I
mean suddenly they're going to let them
die nothing like that you know it's
simply just trying to get the two of
them to work together and initially it's
really this thing of each time they pass
a challenge they basically receive
something they receive part of their
uniforms or they receive some gadgets
and it's basically just saying you guys
need to work together to get past these
challenges and by getting past these
challenges together you're going to form
a bond or at the very least you're going
to form a mutual respect for one another
so that even if you don't become the
best of friends you're gonna have a
respect for what the other is capable of
now the other half of this is that while
they're working together while they're
trying to get through this of course
Maya shows up periodically but they also
have to fight against Goliath and you
know again this is really one of those
things where uh because it's not you
know a super deadly situation initially
Damien calls Goliath off but Goliath you
know doesn't respond right off the bat
eventually he does but he doesn't
respond right off the bat but more so
than that uh you know with these
different traps and and uh scenarios
that have been set up there are a couple
close calls there are a couple instances
where it's possible that they will die
and in fact there is an instance where
Alfred says hey look we need to step in
you know and Batman says no you know
Superman you know like Alfred tells
Superman you got to get in there you got
to save him and Batman says no now this
is very important because it highlights
the very different methods by which
Batman and Superman were late to their
sons because Batman you know lives
within Gotham City and exists to protect
Gotham City in and of itself uh Damien
Wayne's experience as part of the League
of Assassins meant that once he showed
up at Batman's side he was already ahead
of the curve you know he already knew
how to fight he already knew how to uh
how to engage a multitude of enemies and
how to take them out he was already
capable in terms of his abilities so
Batman didn't really have to do a whole
lot the only thing he had to do was
really curb Damian Wayne's bloodlust and
teach him that it's not okay to kill
everybody that you come across it's not
okay to kill every villain that you
fight with Jonathan however he basically
lives in the suburbs you know and so he
was never exposed to constant conflict
he was never tested in the fires of
death and destruction and so he's
basically coming out of this as a
chalkboard you know as a completely
clean board and so he's basically
learning how to fight as he fights he's
learning how to survive as he survives
now it doesn't mean that he's incapable
of doing these things it simply means
that for him he's basically learning
what it means to be a hero outside of
the bits and pieces of of wisdom that he
gets from his father now eventually this
sort of mutual respect begins to blossom
into a friendship when the two of them
are with Goliath and they basically
spend the night uh camped out you know
in order to figure out what they're
going to do when the morning comes
around uh but there's a really funny
scene here here and this this is
actually really touching I really like
this but there's a really cool scene
where Jonathan offers Damien a granola
bar now Damien does the right thing and
he turns it down but in the end he ends
up taking it anyway which I'm not sure
why he did I can't think of very many
men that would willingly eat granola
bars Binny I'm talking about you so um
the two of them also come to the
realization on what it is a Batman and
Superman are looking for right I mean
they're they're not in this with no idea
of what's going on they know that Batman
and Superman want them to work together
and in truth it's really just
stubbornness it's the stubbornness of
boys to kind of Sidetrack here for a
second
um guys and a lot of boys have a very
high level of Pride Damien especially in
this story Jonathan not so much but
Damien definitely has a lot of Pride I
always liken Damien to Vegeta from
Dragon Ball Z in the sense that Damien
does not like admitting when he can't do
something he doesn't like appearing weak
because he was taught you know he was
taught that weakness or to to show
weakness is a failure and it'll lead to
death Neil Batman has curved that and
said Hey look it's always okay to for
help if you need help but Damien still
has a very hard time dealing with that
it's one of the reasons why Damian does
have a lot of people that hate him I
love his character because watching him
evolve from where he used to be to where
he is now is one hell of a journey to
witness it's it's an incredible
experience when you go through and you
read Batman and Robin and you read you
know Robin's Son of Batman uh they're
just some some extremely well told
stories if you can read between the
lines but ultimately because the two of
them come to this realization on what
what Batman and Superman are looking for
but they kind of come to this Unwritten
exception that yeah they need to work
together they come to this Unwritten
agreement that yes they they basically
have to help one another the issue with
this is that once the night passes and
we get back into the day it almost seems
like the the exact same situation they
just don't really work together like
they should and the result is that an
artificial hurricane ends up leading to
uh the two of them being caught unawares
and uh presumably being defeated or more
or less failing The Challenge and so
Superman basically shows up and says hey
look like you guys you guys failed and
this endeavor you know you guys were
supposed to be taught to work as a team
you know the the costumes that you wear
are not just costumes to look good the
costume that you wear aren't just cool
because we all know that having a cape
is amazing like the costumes that you
wear stand for something important it
stands for teamwork it stands for
sacrifice it stands for putting other
people above yourself it stands for the
fact that those people who stand beside
you and conflict are people that have to
be able to trust you and if they can't
trust you then you might as well not be
there it stands for some very very
important things and this is a lesson
they simply haven't learned and so you
know Superman tells them you guys are
simply aren't ready for this you guys
are not ready for this particular uh
this particular Challenge and so making
their way back to uh to the bat cave uh
once they arrive you know with Superman
haven't taken off before them once they
get there they find that Batman and
Superman are under attack
now of course uh you know this is
designed to basically teach them this
final lesson you know this is designed
to teach them that their lies the lives
of people around them depend on them
working together that's really the basis
behind this you know is to teach them
that when other people's lives are on
the line it's not the time to bicker and
it's not the time to argue it's the time
to put yourself in the background and
put the lives of other people first and
that's exactly what Damian and Jonathan
do and it's spectacular to see you know
Damien Wayne is is so intelligent when
it comes to conflict when it comes to
strategic aspects when it comes to being
tactical uh but Jonathan also has some
some strong abilities things that Damien
just can't do and so using Damien's
intelligence alongside Jonathan's
abilities complement each other
perfectly and so they're able to
overcome this force and they're able to
free their fathers and so in doing so
Superman and Batman basically sit down
and they say that's what you guys are
now you guys are not just random dudes
anymore you know you're not just a
couple kids running around with costumes
wanting to play superheroes you guys are
super Heroes now you guys are Protectors
of the planet Earth in the best way you
know how that you guys are effectively
super Sons
so with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end again this is
just a little two-part story but damn I
thought it was good I thought it was so
fun um I I can't wait to see what we
what we get from these two guys and I'll
be honest with you you know once their
power you know what's once the powers of
Jonathan allow him to actually step into
the official Superboy mantle in terms of
what he's capable of and fight some
reasonable foes right alongside his dad
I'd love to see these two on the Justice
League to be honest I'd love to see
Barry Allen and Batman and Superman you
know and uh you know the Green Lanterns
and Damian Wayne and Jonathan can't I'd
love to see them there at the very least
we get something that's that's the
return of like Young Justice or
something along those lines you know
that kind of throws them in there I mean
I guess we have Teen Titans I guess you
could put Jonathan Kent on Teen Titans
hell yeah you could put Jonathan killer
on Teen Titans man dude I would
man do Super Signs Super Signs of
tomorrow let me tell you something this
story is so good do the Cliffhanger at
the end of this video you guys are gonna
be pissed
oh man it is gonna be uh man this story
is amazing okay so in the last video
that we did uh outside of the Blackest
Night great big huge thing uh we covered
Detective Comics a lonely place of
living and that story basically brought
back Tim Drake of the future you know
this idea that Kendrick became Batman of
tomorrow and uh was trying to basically
make his life better by changing the
past the cool thing about this is that
it sort of expands a little bit and it
brings this character back for the same
purpose not really for his for his own
life but for the lives of millions of
people now this is interesting because
in a lot of ways Tim Drake of Tomorrow
is kind of being turned into this
cable-esque character and I'm actually
not against that for those of you guys
who don't know cable is a character from
Marvel Comics who's basically a retcon
machine whenever Marvel wants to change
anything they just send it back into the
past and cable magically changes it
using time travel uh that's one of those
instances I was talking about in the
Detective Comics video where we talked
about how Marvel usually uses time
travel as a plot device as opposed to a
means to either expand on existing
things or to sort of hint at what may
happen later on down the line or even
introduce new characters the cool thing
about this is that initially it picks up
with just Bruce Wayne kind of apparently
he's like he's just reading a book just
sort of chilling when he suddenly met
with the arrival of of future Tim Drake
now again this is interesting because
the last time they met him he just kind
of showed up from the future and he was
trying to take out Batwoman again the
long and short was that it was more or
less featured Tim Drake doing what he
thought was the right thing now of
course this fight between Tim Drake and
Batman is pretty interesting because
it's one of these scenarios where Tim
Drake's kind of put into his place
almost immediately and that's one of the
cool things about this where there's a
lot of kind of back and forth with
regards to the idea that Tim Drake is
taunting Bruce Wayne because he's not
taking the time to understand his
motivations in truth he doesn't really
need to because fresh off the mind of
Bruce Wayne is the idea the Tim Drake
showed up from the future previously to
kill Batwoman and so in this instance
it's the exact same scenario but this is
like when Bruce Wayne fought Damien
Wayne in Injustice do not be confused
about your place in the bigger picture
that's what this is you know Tim Drake
sure he puts on the Batman mantle he
puts on the the cloak and cow but he
ain't Batman he's not Bruce Wayne and
that's exactly what this is where
previously he basically you know he
knocked out Bruce Wayne by playing on a
weakness Bruce usually always learns and
so in this instance he takes him out
quick fast and in a hurry or at least
he's immediately on him that fast and
doesn't really spare a whole lot of time
for emotion sentiment different things
like that I remember those circumstances
are a little bit different you know when
future Tim Drake showed up it was a sob
story and oh you know things are going
to be so bad it's not that same way
anymore things were a lot more ruthless
between the two of them neither of them
were taking the time to learn the
other's motivations or just immediately
jumping in and they're going in for the
attack now again because of the fact
that this is Bruce Wayne and he is the
guy who trained all the other members of
the bat family with the exception of
Damian Wayne We would wholeheartedly
expect Bruce Wayne to immediately take
out Tim Drake I mean it wouldn't really
the fight would be pretty brutal just
because Tim's learned a lot but he's not
on the same level as Bruce when it comes
to being a fighter and so again much
like we saw in the Detective comic story
he uses subterfuge he uses a momentary
weakness he pulls a gun and shoots Bruce
he grabs Bruce takes him underground you
know takes him back to the bat cave
incapacitates him and leaves him there
and so for that point he jumps to The
Fortress of Solitude this is cool
because his future Tim break going
against Superman now again this is
designed to hit at that Ingenuity it's
designed to hit it the idea that with
Tim Drake it's really more of brain over
Brawn when it comes to like the finesse
that Batman has with fighting for
example Superman doesn't really have
that it's just I'm gonna punch you
really really hard and hopefully you get
knocked out of course with a lot of this
kind of taking place after the events of
Oz effect you know Superman kind of
getting the forges of solitude back in
order different things like that Tim
Drake showing up he's immediately
grabbed by Superman now of course
because of the fact that Superman has
things like x-ray vision so on and so
forth super hearing he immediately picks
up on the fact that this is not Bruce
Wayne I mean sure a couple bullets are
fired and the fact they use as a gun is
a pretty good giveaway but he picks up
on the idea that it's Tim Drake just
kind of listening to his voice different
things along those lines but again the
intelligence of Tim Drake the Ingenuity
firing off some capsules a sort of amid
this gas of sorts that slow Superman
down allowing Tim Drake the ability to
basically hack into and take over the
Kryptonian armor now the funny thing
about this is Tim should not normally be
able to do that the Kryptonian battle
armor is supposed to only be used by
kryptonians because it requires you to
speak and to read Kryptonian but Tim
Drake's argument is the Superman in my
future is a person who taught me how to
do that any hints at the idea that the
Superman from his future is Connor Kent
so again bringing back all that stuff
into Super sons of tomorrow bring back
all that stuff into Tim Drake Conor Kent
becomes Superman in the future what ends
up happening is in this battle where
Superman is easily able to subdue future
Tim Drake what is it taking place is
Superman himself is kind of immersed in
this capsule of red solar radiation now
this is genius we've seen it before in
fact this was one of the first times
that I believe red Kryptonite was
introduced into DC Comics when it was
much the same way Superman was Trapped
In Like A Red solar radiation uh capsule
of sorts but it is interesting because
what this does is again it hits the
nature of Tim Drake the intelligence the
Ingenuity he cannot go toe-to-toe with
Superman he does not have the power that
the strength or anything to be able to
pull that off but if he can't fight
Superman head on then work around
Superman and again that goes back into
the nature of Tim but of course we end
up learning his motivation for being
here is to take out Superboy the son of
Superman now at this point we switch
over to the Teen Titans and this is
pretty cool because because you know
with basically Superman subdued Batman
subdued this basically leaves the
landscape open for everything to go on
with regards to Tim Drake himself now of
course watching everything unfold
showing up at the house of Lois Lane and
uh Superman you know in Metropolis
itself finding that you know Jonathan
Kent is gone when he gets there what we
end up doing is we pick up with Jonathan
actually alongside the Teen Titans now
in truth Jonathan is not actually a team
titan yet that's kind of been an
on-running theme in the super Sun
stories in the sense that basically
Jonathan wants to join the Teen Titans
but he's not really a teenager he's kind
of a pre-teenager he's about a year or
two younger than Damian and so the
result is that he just really can't be
on the team it's not the free teenage
free Teen Titans it's the Teen Titans so
I mean you know same reason the Teen
Titans can't really be on the Titans but
the whole idea here is that they're
largely just kind of facing off against
a group called The hangman now this is
par for the course when it comes to the
Teen Titans right for for those of you
guys who are not reading the Teen Titans
publication at the moment it's amazing
and I highly suggest you check it out
it's really one of those things where it
is a great combination of what people
think of when they think of Teen Titans
historically speaking the Teen Titans
has been a team where it focuses on the
inner personal relationships with the
characters the kind of strain they ran
into as a team itself just kind of
working together with their own
individual personalities how they mesh
how they conflict and in fighting
against you know various enemies and and
so on and so forth and that's largely
how the team has played out in DC
rebirth so far you know Damien Wayne
isn't really the same kind of a leader
that Tim Drake was where Tim Drake led
by you know saying hey let's do this
let's do that really feeding into the
opinions asking people how they can
contribute you know Damian Wayne is more
like we're gonna do that and that's just
the way it is he's really more iron
fisted now that fits into the nature of
Damian Wayne in terms of how he's been
depicted over the course of his life and
DC Comics and so on and so forth but it
is cool because where the Teen Titans is
designed to focus on the interpersonal
relations of the team it's also designed
to basically build up the character of
Damien kind of giving him social skills
where he previously didn't really have
any didn't know how to relate to people
didn't really know how to deal with
people how to talk to people anything
along those lines and so the result is
that where they are able to hold their
own to a degree some of the enemies are
taken out pretty quickly and subdued by
the cops and when the question becomes
who was it they basically took them out
if it was Kid Flash if it was Beast Boy
whatever they came maybe we ended up
finding out it was actually Jonathan
Kent now of course Damien Wayne is the
one who figures it out and basically
shoots some gas to kind of knock him out
and that's really it but it's a funny
little moment because you know it's
Jonathan just kind of sneaking out of
his house to go join the Teen Titans
even though he's not supposed to be
there kind of trying to force himself
onto the team now in truth Jonathan's
probably one of my absolute favorite
characters in DC rebirth I love the way
his character's done you know because
he's just a kid that's desperate to fit
in he's a kid that's desperate to be
accepted and that's kind of the irony of
all this because in truth he's probably
the most powerful member if he were to
join the Teen Titans I mean it's
basically Superman on the Justice League
just in a much smaller form but it is
cool because for the most part the team
Titan's argument is it's not necessarily
about how powerful we are it's about how
well we work as a team and that's the
big kicker keep in mind you don't
necessarily need Superman to win a
conflict but with regards to the whole
function of the team it's I mean sure if
we have Superboy on here then almost all
of our problems will be solved I mean
you know once this Powers begin to
evolve to a point where he's on par with
his father he's exceedingly capable and
it'll say to take away from the basis of
the team whereas if you don't have
Superboy there then you gotta you know
focus on the powers of Starfire and
Aqualad and Kid Flash and Beast Boy and
you know Damien Wayne you gotta focus on
their abilities what it is that they can
and can't do and it creates more of a
comprehensive relationship between the
characters so it is pretty cool it is
pretty interesting to see them function
without Superboy but it also kind of
begs the question when is he gonna get
on the team because we all know it's
only a matter of time
but the cool thing about this is that in
the middle of this whole scenario
they're all met with the arrival of Tim
Drake now remember when it came to DC
Comics the original Teen Titans of the
new 52 it wasn't very well received by
fans because a lot of people were very
angry at the idea that the original Teen
Titans as they knew them had gone away
because remember guys the Teen Titans
were huge I mean back in the day when
the Teen Titans were at their Peak they
outsold everything they outsold Batman
they outsold Superman they outsold the
Justice League it was the highest
selling publication DC had for for a
pretty good clip of time now a lot of
modern day fans of the Teen Titans come
out of the show it's one of those
interesting things because there's like
all these arguments that rage between
like Teen Titans Go versus Teen Titans
and it is hilarious we were at a con
kind of a Sidetrack here we were at a
con one day and there was uh we had a
huge panel that we were doing and Benny
made a comment about how I was watching
Teen Titans Go and didn't really mind it
and people in the room were just like
boo they hated Teen Titans Go and it was
it was pretty fun it was it was pretty
hilarious but that's where a lot of
modern day fans come from and so because
they come from that they want to see the
original iteration of of the Teen Titans
that they're used to now DC tried to
satisfy that in the new 52 with regards
to a story called Titan's hunt which was
designed to kind of explain the
backstory to the new 52 Teen Titans at
the end of the day it was really more
fan service it was a mini series it
didn't really give people the kind of
satisfaction they were looking for but
50 of something's better than 100 of
nothing so at the end of the day they
weren't too upset about it well of
course with the DC rebirth line it does
bring back a lot of the characters that
people are familiar with Starfire Raven
Beast Boy things like that the team of
course being spearheaded by Damien Wayne
is a little bit different but it does
create something pretty interesting but
the whole base is behind the modern day
Teen Titans is that it's really
predicated on the house that Tim Drake
built so to speak and so a lot of the
technology that's been repurposed a lot
of the things that have been you know
redeveloped or improved upon by Damien
Wayne are predicated on what Tim Drake
built and that's the reason why he's
able to hack into it because effectively
Damien way moved into a house that Tim
Drake already had the keys to and so
he's basically accessing something that
he's always been able to access because
nobody would expect Tim Drake to show up
here it was very much Damian Wayne
saying what reason would Tim Drake have
to come here and take over the team
Titans he knows it's my thing besides
he's off you know doing his own thing so
again it is kind of interesting but they
basically let a wolf under the hen house
that's exactly what's going on here but
with regards to uh future Tim his
argument is look I am here because
Jonathan Ken is going to unleash holy
hell on the world he's going to become
an outright villain this is kind of
funny because when people were reading
the solicitations for super sons of
Tomorrow the big question they had is
Will Jonathan Kent become Superboy Prime
that's one of the things that people
kept asking about this and in truth it's
not that far off when Tim Drake
basically tells Raven to read his mind
and relay those thoughts to the rest of
the Teen Titans what we end up seeing is
this future where you end up having
Damian Wayne who becomes Batman you end
up having Jonathan Kim who becomes
Superman in this future lines are
basically drawn the friendship between
Jonathan Kim and Damian Wayne seems to
have gone awry and the result is that
Jonathan Kent loses his mind Metropolis
is totally obliterated and millions of
lives are lost and so the result is that
Tim Drake is trying to keep this future
from happening and so as a result of
this he immediately subdues Jonathan
Kent the problem is that he
underestimates Jonathan remember when it
comes to his character his powers at the
moment are tied into his emotions he
does not have the kind of control his
father has and so in this moment with
Tim Drake basically underestimating
Jonathan's State of Mind where he goes
to subdue him and Jonathan begins to
panic suddenly his powers begin to go
awry and when they do Damian's Damian's
role is get out of here because if you
let off all this energy you basically
let off this kind of solar flare ability
you know so to speak from what we saw in
the New 52 Superman line you're going to
kill everybody in this room and so it
was quite literally Jonathan Kent racing
into the sky and letting all this energy
off you know and exploding for lack of a
better word Raven basically protecting
everybody from the blast but then we end
up finding out that this entire
situation of Tim Drake in the past is
being monitored in the future by three
people the first person is Connor Kent
of course you know we've talked about
him before Conor can being one of the
Clones of Superman following the actual
Superman's death back in the early 1990s
the other two people are characters that
we have not seen yet in DC rebirth the
first one is Cass see sandsmark and the
second one is Bart Allen with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end that Cliffhanger if you are
new here to Comics explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like
explanations on Cassie sandsmark and
Bart Allen will be forthcoming in the
next video
okay so getting back into Super sun is
really the conclusion of super Sons
which is actually really really good
this brings back something called hyper
time and in truth we've kind of seen
hyper time sporadically throughout DC
rebirth and in all honesty I thought it
was a concept that I would never have to
talk about I was hoping it was something
I could just kind of avoid and just not
really discussed because hyper time is
not the best idea I mean it it works for
the purpose it serves and it would have
worked better if everybody had used it
the problem is that they didn't so
what's hyper time okay hyper time was
DC's attempt to copy Marvel's handling
of the Multiverse so with Marvel let's
say that you have like a singular line
on a piece of paper so this straight
line represents the main Marvel Universe
now this line has been destroyed and
created multiple times in fact eight
times to be exact uh because the
Multiverse has been created and
destroyed you know eight different times
so we have this straight line and this
main line is just the main Marvel
Universe this is the story where Bruce
Banner became the Incredible Hulk this
is the story where the original Civil
War event happened so this is the main
Marvel Universe line but let's say
somewhere along this line we put a dot
and we can call it 1984 and we can say
Peter Parker becomes Venom all right so
this is this is Secret Wars in 1984 and
this is the story where Peter Parker
discovers the Venom symbiote but let's
say within this dot the following events
happen Secret Wars 2000 or Secret Wars
1984 takes place Peter Parker discovers
the Venom symbiote Peter Parker brings
it back to Earth and then Peter Parker
goes to visit the Fantastic Four and
Reed Richards says that's actually a
sentient symbiote that you're wearing as
a sentient organism it's not just a
black suit and is trying to take you
over and so Peter Parker casts it off
all that takes place in that little dot
now let's create a branch offline
alright so we have a line that branches
off and goes forward keeps going along
the forward in the same four direction
as that main line now we can say in that
line Peter Parker does not get rid of
the Venom symbiote that is how Marvel
handles their Multiverse it's Branch
universe theory you have a main set of
events that take place and then it's but
what if something else happened instead
and then it branches off into an
alternate universe now we never really
find out what happens in the future of
those alternate realities we get a story
about one moment in that alternate
reality another one of those lines may
be what if the Punisher family was not
killed in the park shootout that's what
those little Branch off lines are
they're just moments in time where
things broke off from the main Marvel
Universe now this is how DC handles the
Multiverse so we're gonna have three
lines we're gonna have one line under
that we're gonna have another line and
under that we're gonna have another line
and the very top line is called Earth
one and the very bottom of the second
line is called Earth two and the very
bottom line is called Earth three and
that's it that's how DC usually handles
their Multiverse Earth one is all the
stories that have buried out at least
before Christ on infinite Earth all the
stories that have Barry Allen and before
crisis on invented Earth 2 is all the
stories that had Jay Garrick basically
all the DC Comics from the 1940s and
Earth 3 is called the crime syndicate of
America where the Justice League were
bad guys now let's say all three of
those lines suddenly stop we can draw a
line right through them all right that
line that goes through all three lines
that's crisis on infiniters all those
those all those universes are gone there
is no more Earth one Earth two or three
Earth s none of that stuff exists
anymore instead coming out of those
three lines we have one line and that
line is called New Earth that's
everything after crisis on infinite
nurse running all all the way up to
2006's Infinite Crisis and that's it
it's just one line one universe
everything that happened in DC Comics
between 1985 to 2005 all happen in that
one line now 2005's Infinite Crisis
brings back those three lines is
basically what it is but during the time
when everything was operating on that
one line Grant Morrison and Mark Wade
had this idea and they said well we
can't do alternate realities anymore
because there are no more alternate
realities so instead what we're going to
do is we're going to invent hyperton and
what we're going to say is that instead
of there being alternate universe that
have always existed out there we'll say
alternate timelines basically it's the
same thing it was bringing back
alternate realities but just calling
them something else and so what they
said is well maybe the flash goes back
in time and does this and instead of
things happening the way they always did
on that one line then it branches off
into another line and something else
happens and it was bringing in all these
different alternate realities now it
would have worked basically what you
would have had is DC's version of
Marvel's handling of alternate realities
and that would have been it the problem
is that no one used hyper time except
for like Grant Morrison and Mark Wade
and so what you would have is in the
Flash stories you would have you have a
vents would take place there'd be
alternate realities and then you
wouldn't have that anywhere else and so
it threw the reader off and it confused
the heck out of them because people were
like but I thought there was only ever
one timeline but you read The Flash
comics and it's like well there's a ton
of timelines there's all these different
alternate realities out here and all
these crazy things and people are just
like but that doesn't make any sense
what DC did at least what they seem to
be trying to do with regards to DC
rebirth and especially new 52 is they're
trying to blend in hyper time with their
handling of the Multiverse so what DC
basically says is yeah there's these
alternate realities out there Earth one
Earth two or three like they presumably
exist out there somewhere we don't
really know what's going on with them
and we don't know exactly how it all
fits in because of what what Manhattan's
done but we can say they all exist out
there but in addition to those universes
that have always been there if the flash
goes back in time and changes something
well then hyper time gets invoked and
it's an alternate reality and that's
what this story is this story is
basically DC's version of Marvel's what
if what if lies The Source that's what
you can imagine this to be if this story
super sons of tomorrow was thrown into
Marvel Comics it would be what if
Superboy killed everybody like I mean
that's basically what it would be you
know what if Superboy killed a million
people in DC Universe that's what the
story would be called it's essentially a
future where Superboy had killed a
million people for whatever reason which
we'll talk about in this video and then
basically that Futures version of the
Justice League and Tim Drake who is
Batman went back in time to try to stop
it that's basically what this is
so if that has melted your brain a
little bit feel free to kind of scroll
back and watch it a couple more times
hopefully it makes sense and it kind of
sinks in or give yourself a few minutes
I know that when I read things that are
kind of confusing I have to give myself
maybe 10 or 15 minutes to kind of let it
sink in and then it'll unders then like
it'll make sense to me and that kind of
a thing but the fact remains you know
getting caught up so far we've pretty
much run over it I mean Tim Drake is
basically Batman from the future he
showed up and he's trying to stop some
event that will lead to Jonathan Kent
the son of Superman killing a million
people the result is that where he
initially where Tim Drake had initially
shown up and then basically Ambush the
Titans and then try to overpower
Jonathan Kent the result was that
Jonathan Ken had basically charged up
and let off this massive amount of solar
energy now the issue with this is that
with Jonathan Kim essentially knocked
unconscious what happened is that Tim
Drake used it as a means to argue see I
was right I told you guys he was
dangerous now this is one of those
things where Tim Drake caused the
problem that he was trying to avoid or
at least showed people what it was that
Jonathan the kid could do by pushing and
prodding him but he actually has a point
if Tim Drake was able to push Jonathan
Kim to the point where he would let off
the solar you know solar flare of sorts
albeit with a small amount of damage
imagine what would happen if somebody
that Jonathan Kemp truly trusted pushed
him to the extreme and forced him to
just let off this massive amount of
energy not only that what if he flew
into the Sun and absorbed all this solar
radiation came back to Earth and then
exploded imagine the damage that he
would do then and so that's the concern
that Tim Drake has Jonathan Kent's gonna
destroy Metropolis in the future he's
going to kill millions of people and
it's a scenario that can be avoided it's
Tim Drake's attempt to change the past
now picking up with Jonathan Kin of
course having been rescued by Damian
Wayne the interesting thing about this
is that Damian Wayne looks at the solar
flare of Superboy as something that can
be used where on the surface most people
would say well it's exceedingly
dangerous and they could result in the
destruction of everything and Damian
Wayne's mind is this idea if Jonathan
can be taught how to control it then
it's a power he can use so long as he
doesn't abuse it or anything like that
but in Damien's mind the reason why you
know Tim Drake's future came into
existence was because Jonathan developed
his new power and there was no one there
to teach him how to use it now again the
other half of this is of course the Teen
Titans of tomorrow and this brings back
some characters that have been missing
for quite some time Cassie sansmore
Connor Kent Bart Allen of course we did
an explanation video on BART Allen which
you're welcome to check out if you want
a wholesale understanding of his
character but the fact remains that
they're basically the Teen Titans of
Tomorrow the Teen Titans of the future
Bart Allen of course playing the role of
the flash Cassie sandsmark playing the
role of Wonder Woman and Conor Kim
playing the role of Superman again we
don't really know what happened to their
normal stand-in characters but the
result is that Tim Drake kind of comes
from their future and it's sort of
interesting because it seems like
there's a bit of not really distrust so
much as a disagreement on what role they
should take where the Teen Titans seem
to have just kind of been like well I
mean you know if we could stop it that's
cool Tim Drake is like well then let's
actually stop it he just jumps into the
past and tries to find a way to take out
Superboy Jonathan Kent now it is kind of
interesting because of course as we saw
in the first video Tim Drake had
incapacitated both Batman and Superman
which removed them from the equation and
at that point it was really just kind of
left to the Teen Titans to try to pull
it off and where Tim Drake initially
meets with the other Titans absent uh
Damien and Superboy who are currently
you know on the road recuperating Tim
Drake actually makes a pretty compelling
argument Superboy does know who I am but
if I was able to push him to the extreme
to the point that he would lose his mind
and he would basically destroy the
entirety of Titan's Tower then what does
that say of someone like Damien Wayne
betrays him he trusts you guys he
believes in you guys and he cares about
you guys if you betray his trust or you
push him to the edge the amount of
energy because it's directly intertwined
with his emotional state means that he
would be even more heartbroken which
means it would be even more damage and
so again it's actually pretty intriguing
and it's a pretty legit argument the
other half of this is the nature of
Raven in the sense that Raven almost
sort of goes along with this idea of Tim
Drake and she really kind of buys into
it you know her argument is look if what
you say is that Jonathan Kent has a
level of power that he hasn't really
experienced before he's got a new energy
this super bomb that he can't really
control and that a time will come when
someone will push him to the edge his
emotions will get the better of him and
he'll wipe everything out of existence
then we have to control him we have to
contain him if for no other reason than
to keep him in stasis so we can teach
him how to use his powers you know it's
really one of those things where it's
like we're capturing him but we're doing
it for his own benefit and it's kind of
intriguing because this creates a Rift
of sorts among the Teen Titans the
scenario on one side you know Aqualad
and starfires well I mean you know let's
not be so heavy-handed you know there's
a lot that we don't know about all this
the other side of Raven is but we have
Tim Drake here and he's already given us
the future so we know what's going to
happen and that's why it's so cool
that's one of the reasons why the
writing of Teen Titans was so popular
and remained so popular among fans it's
not a pretty white kids with problems
comic book it's a story where it's like
man these are some serious issues that
these kids are dealing with and a lot of
philosophical themes and different
things like that now of course the other
half of this is that in the future
Connor Cassie sandsmark and Bart Allen
they're trying to locate Tim Drake
within time the problem with this is
that remember when you're in the future
and you're looking at the present day
you're basically looking at a flowing
river and so you know if you have like a
a pod or you have like an object sitting
in that River it's not still it doesn't
just stay there it doesn't sit in one
place it flows along the river and so
what they're literally trying to do is
cast a fishing line and try to grab that
object out of the river it's gonna be
hard to do you can't just reach in and
grab it because while it's there now in
an instant it could be somewhere else
and it can be anywhere along the time
stream it's a needle in the haystack so
the cool thing about this is that Raven
you know while the the future Titans are
trying to Anchor onto Tim Drake and
while they do manage to get a hold of
him which basically says look we can now
track his location Raven basically uses
a little a little bit of telepathic
Voodoo offers a distraction of sorts you
know has everybody fixed Titan Tower and
then just disappears alongside Tim Drake
and Beast Boy and it's kind of cool
because in their mind you know in the
minds of all these different superheroes
everything's being fixed in the mind of
Starfire and Kid Flash and Aqualad oh
man they're fixing Titan's Tower we'll
take care of that first and then we'll
go after Connor Camp when in reality
none of that's happening it's just as in
shambles As It Ever Was and so which is
again the telepathic Powers you know the
telepathic abilities that Raven has to
kind of mess with the minds of people
which is kind of cool but at this point
we switch over to uh to really the last
bit of the story switching over to you
know the Superman number 38 and again
this really picks up with the idea that
the Teen Titans to a degree feel kind of
a trade by Raven but using the powers of
Aqualad are also able to locate where it
is that Jonathan and uh and Damian Wayne
are located now of course once they find
them then it's like okay we have have to
figure out a way to contain this
situation now of course the immediate
reaction of both Damien and Jonathan is
one to attack and it's also kind of cool
because where Damien Wayne did assemble
his own Teen Titans and were each member
of the Titans do have their own History
either as heroes or just kind of living
in isolation but are well aware of their
powers and what they're capable of
Damian Wayne's job as a leader is to
know their strengths and weaknesses and
so while he has no powers to speak of he
does have the mind of Bruce Wayne which
means he knows how to easily overcome
each and every one of these Titans now
of course this leads to a stalemate of
Swords just because of the fact that
aqualads like look guys enough like this
is ridiculous we need to calm down
everybody needs to chill and we need to
talk this out what this also leads to is
the arrival of Conor Kim and Bard Allen
and Cassie sandspark now it's not
immediate instead it's actually super
boy saying okay look if everybody's
really on the hunt for us you know
Jonathan Kim's like if everybody's
really looking for us then we have to go
to the Fortress of Solitude it's the
safest place for us to go it's virtually
impenetrable except by those who know
explicitly how it works which is to say
those who can just speak Kryptonian or
understand the Kryptonian language which
are forced Tim Drake does which is how
he was able to penetrate it because he
was taught by Conor Kent in the future
but it is cool because when they get
there the place is in shambles because
remember at the beginning of the story
Tim Drake showed up he used his
knowledge of the Kryptonian language to
Infiltrate The Fortress of Solitude and
then subdue Superman now the other half
of this is Jonathan now this is kind of
cool because what tomasi is doing is it
almost kind of seems like he's drawing
on a bit of Dragon Ball if I'm gonna be
honest with you guys it's almost kind of
what it reminded me of I mean I don't
know if Peter J tomasi watches Dragon
Ball or even knows what it is but it is
kind of one of those cool scenes you
know back when Dragon when Dragon Ball Z
first launched Gohan was first
introduced when his father was in a
dangerous situation Gohan's power would
emerge through his emotional state and
he would let off this massive amount of
energy his power level would Skyrocket
you know and it would get really really
cool it was one of those funny things
his power was tied to his emotions the
angrier he got the more Reckless and the
more powerful he got until he was able
to control his fighting abilities and
different things like that but with
Jonathan Kent it's the same way because
it's his dad it's his anchor to the
world he lives in rescuing his dad from
this container also sets in motion the
idea that Jonathan Kim has a supernova
power that he can't necessarily control
and in this instance because his
emotional state shifts in the extreme
his powers just kind of start running
awry to the point that he can't control
him and his Energy starts building up
and this proves the argument of Tim
Drake someone is going to push Jonathan
Kim to the edge and his emotions are
going to take over reason and logic will
take a back seat his power will start
surging and start enveloping outwards
and when it does a massive amount of
energy is going to explode and that's
going to be the end of everyone and so
it's cool because with the arrival of
Bart Allen with the arrival of Cassie
sandersmark with the arrival of Connor
Kent we basically get them fighting
alongside Superman and the modern day
Teen Titans and in truth this is a Teen
Titans dream I mean those people who
were reading DC back in like the 1990s
they're just like yes
those folks who are reading uh reading
uh Young Justice in the early 2000s
they're in the exact same boat it's it's
a return to familiarity for them even if
it's only momentary for those existing
fans they finally get to see Connor Kent
alongside Superman they finally get to
see Bart Allen returned to the DC
landscape Cassie sandsmark you know the
second Wonder Girl they get to see all
these things begin to sort of grow and
progress and so on and so forth and
things begin to kind of shape up and
take their rightful place now again it's
temporary for those of you guys who are
non-comic readers fans see this as DC
kind of opening the door and saying hey
guys like look what's behind the door
over here I mean we're going to close it
back but like that's what's waiting on
you in the future of DC rebirth and it
makes people so excited because in this
moment you know with this conflict
beginning to sort of wind down Windows
up taking place here is that you end up
having Tim Drake who kind of jumps in
and absorbs all this energy that's
essentially being let off by Jonathan
kind of absorbs it into himself and then
vanishes into the time stream now of
course this leads directly into the
aftermath but one of the things that I
want you guys to notice here is that
where Tim Drake absorbs all this energy
and he's just kind of shot into quote
unquote hyper time or into the
Multiverse we end up seeing think all
these different Universal events that
have ever taken place this is very
reminiscent of the button remember
during the button storyline when Batman
and the Flash were thrown into the
Multiverse it was all these alternate
realities the scene from DC Universe
rebirth number one the one shot that
said all this in motion when the when I
guess when Cosa quality West finally
came back you know the idea of crisis on
infinite Earth is shown here the
original anti-monitor you know Zero Hour
crisis in time when Hal Jordan was
parallaxed and went crazy you know and
killed all the Guardians all these
extremely important moments are shown
here all these things basically every
single event that's ever happened in DC
Comics is represented in this Multiverse
and what this means is that this version
of Tim Drake can land anywhere Tim Drake
could land in the middle of crisis on
infinite Earth Tim Drake could land in
the middle of emerald Twilight in the
middle of Zero Hour crisis in time he
could land in the middle of Infinite
Crisis this is DC reminding us where
things stand there's a reason why you
don't see the original Superman from
1938 here you don't see Action Comics
number one represented here what DC
seems to be saying is okay so here's how
things progress biriana went back in
time and saved his mom's life and that
spawned Flashpoint and Barry I was like
man this Flashpoint Universe sucks so I
gotta let my mom die in order to make
sure everything goes back to normal he
goes back in time to let his mom die and
things were supposed to go back to
normal but like Dr Manhattan intervened
for some reason and we don't know why
and changed everything and so we got all
the stories from 2011 going forward
until DC Universe rebirth number one
that seems to be what DC is saying here
I'm not going to take that as an
absolute certainty and we won't really
know until the whole rebirth initiative
ends and then we're with the final DC
Universe in terms of like Hey we're done
changing everything we're done
retconning everything we are finally
done We're Off to the Races now here's
how it's going to be going forward we
won't know until we get to that point
until presumably doomsday clock-ins is
really what I think all that stuff I
think Doomsday Clock will be where we
learn everything that Dr Manhattan did
but
okay so picking up with the epilogue of
uh super Sun's rebirth this is it's
really fun I mean dude I I love the
whole idea of like super sons of
tomorrow but I love the Teen Titans and
the super Sun's Comics it's so fun this
is one of the things I really enjoy I
was never like a huge reader of Teen
Titans I mean I watched the show back in
the day but I was never like an avid
Teen Titans fan and so for a lot of
people who have been like who've been
reading Teen Titans for years I'm sure
for a lot of you guys this is just like
yeah this isn't anything I haven't seen
before I love it but I've seen all this
before but to me it's brand new this is
all basically new stuff to me and I love
this whole thing I especially love the
character of Jonathan Kim Jonathan Ken
is definitely my favorite character in
DC rebirth like it's it's just it's
amazing how hilarious he is because he's
just like a teen and he has fun and all
that kind of stuff but again this is a
really really important moment because
remember in the last video we had talked
about how Tim Drake had come from the
future as a byproduct of the fact that
somewhere along the line Jonathan Kemp
Superman's son would essentially develop
his fathers who are really you know
Superman solar flare power basically
allowing him to kind of discharge this
massive amount of solar energy due to
the fact that Damien Wayne would betray
him at some point and so as a result
when he discharges all this solar energy
it would wipe out the city of metropolis
uh it would kill like a million people
and then in turn a Superboy would just
kind of become like you know this
character that everybody see everybody's
looking for to kind of try to track down
but the whole idea of Tim Drake was to
find a way to go back into the past and
stop it from happening so it's pretty
cool for what it was because this
version of Tim really became a much
darker version of the character that he
is now but the fact remains here that
when the kind of climax to the super
sons of tomorrow's story happen and
Jonathan Kent began to kind of emanate
this solar flare power essentially Tim
Drake absorbed that energy and was then
thrown into the time stream and this is
huge because again this is one of those
instances when DC gives us like these
little flashbacks to basically tell us
here are the things that have happened
and here are the things that haven't
happened so for example I mean you see
from like this opening this opening page
here you know this giant splash page
that things like uh crisis on infinite
Earth happen things like uh you know
Infinite Crisis Superboy Prime that
happened but also DC Universe rebirth
number one uh the events of forever evil
those things took place too now again
what I'm really expecting from DC to
kind of Sidetrack here for a second but
what I'm really expecting from DC is to
give us this kind of Zero Hour crisis
and time event which is to say we might
necessarily get a crisis but once the
whole rebirth thing is basically done
which is to say when we get an
explanation of like what Dr Manhattan
did and how his actions impacted and
changed everything that it'll eventually
segue into DC most likely giving us like
a timeline like basically here are all
the things that have happened that are
in continuity like that's kind of what I
expect to take place but the fact
remains here that at this point Tim
Drake uh this future version of Tim
Drake is in the time Stream So basically
he could be anywhere and at any point in
time we have no idea where he is he
could end up at any point from the
events of crisis on infinite Earth all
the way up to the modern day so who
knows when he would pop up and it's cool
because it allows DC to really offer
even if they wanted to like an ongoing
series or a mini series or something
like that where this future version of
Tim Drake is our he's our tour guide for
the Multiverse so really for like the
entire timeline of DC Comics there's a
lot of stuff that you can do the other
half of this is something that kind of
caught me by surprise with this
aftermath this epilogue is that we
basically basically have the titans of
tomorrow meeting the new superheroes
meaning the existing superheroes you
know the current of Superman and you
know the Teen Titans and so on Superman
doesn't know who they are and that's
kind of the interesting thing remember
this on the surface our initial response
if we've forgotten a couple things our
initial response would be but they
should know each other like they should
definitely definitely know who the other
is and so again I want to take this this
bit of a second this little you know a
little bit of an opportunity I want to
talk about Superman for a second a lot
of people are still a little bit
confused about Superman reborn they're
really just kind of confused about how
that works and how the new Superman's
origin story works and all that kind of
good stuff so to offer an explanation
here let's take DC rebirth when DC
rebirth kicked off which is to say the
release of DC Universe rebirth number
one we had two Supermen in the main DC
Universe we had the Superman that arose
during the events of you know the new 52
basically when DC rebooted and said we
wanted you guys we want you guys to
treat superheroes like we've never
published them before we had this new
younger version of Superman and then we
had the classic Superman and the whole
idea with this is that it was DC
basically saying hey look you know
somebody did something somebody messed
with things now because of what's
happened in DC rebirth so far what we
can kind of presume here and again you
know it's still a little bit fuzzy in
terms of how it works what we can I can
kind of presume here is that when
Flashpoint happened and you know Barry
Allen went back in time you know saved
his mom's life and then went back in
time and let her die after realizing how
bad everything got and so on and so
forth uh Dr Manhattan stepped in and
messed with things presumably he made
the new Superman whatever the case may
be but the result here is that we ended
up having this quote unquote new
universe that existed and then you had
classic Superman who basically left his
universe and arrived in this one and so
that's how we had those two Supermen
there we basically had two versions of
the same character who were just from
two different universes more or less two
different points in time and the result
was that with Superman reborn it was
basically taking those two versions of
Superman bringing them together and then
just erasing the entire history of the
individual characters and so as it
stands right now with this version of
Superman that we see here this one in
this story right now and the one that
we've seen after the events of Superman
reborn basically there is no classic
Superman in the sense of like the death
of Superman all those old stories
there's also no New 52 Superman what
there is is there is this Superman and
then whatever parts of his past DC wants
to keep intact so we know that this
version died back in 1992 you know in
The Death of Superman that happened he
was killed by doomsday oh we know that
those kind of events have taken place
and the new origin was given to us as
part of the aftermath of Superman reborn
so again that's kind of what this
version is supposed to be in in terms of
the role he plays he's basically classic
Superman but in terms of you know this
being an exact copy not necessarily the
case that classic Superman that we're
familiar with that one's basically gone
and this is kind of like a merged
version of the two characters hopefully
that makes sense to you guys um I don't
really know how to explain it any
clearer than that so I don't know you
might have to kind of investigate
outside of my videos in order to find a
way that's more conducive to to your
ability to understand it but the fact
remains here it is kind of cool because
again this is why this version of
Superman doesn't know these Titans now
if Superman Reborn never happened and
The New 52 Superman died and the classic
Superman was here and his origin story
was never Rewritten he would definitely
know these characters he would say yeah
Connor and I remember you how come you
don't remember me you're basically a
cloned version of me from when I died
and Lex Luthor made you how come you
don't remember me with Bart Allen it
would be like yeah I remember you like
you're the grandson of Barry Allen you
were brought to the 20th century because
your powers were out of control and then
you know Wally West and a handful of
others managed to find a way to keep him
in check and basically set you back you
know I remember your whole past I
remember you when you were this tall
like I mean I I I imagine that's how
Superman would respond but again he
doesn't necessarily have all the same
memories but we would kind of expect him
to you know to a degree but again that's
why it's so so interesting and that's
why it's so intriguing is because DC is
very much playing it by ear now even
then with like the the character of
Beast Boy his initial response is well I
feel like I know that girl Cassie
sandsmark like I feel like we've met
before and this is really kind of like
DC hitting home with the idea that maybe
there is a connection here that if Dr
Manhattan stepped in and modified
everybody's memories and changed
everything around and moved these pieces
around the board in order to make it
look different than it actually was then
maybe this effect is starting to wear
off but again we can't really take that
by just like one phrase by one sentence
from Beast Boy can't really ride that as
an absolute certainty at this point it's
just kind of like haphazard guessing now
the other funny thing about this is is
Kid Flash I love Kid Flash love Kid
Flash he's almost as awesome as Jonathan
Kitt and the funny thing about this is
that where everybody's kind of talking
about the aftermath and the titans of
tomorrow and whether or not they should
ask about the future and if they should
get answers and different things like
that kid flashes whole response is hey I
got something better than anything we
could have gotten and when people are
like what he's like a selfie
which is amazing because it's so easy to
forget in the story that they are
teenagers I mean they're just young kids
you know their kids just kind of having
a great time being superheroes also
dealing with teenage issues Raven gets
pissed off and destroys the phone it is
pretty funny you know these these these
little interactions things like that but
the other half of this is that this
basically picks up with the whole idea
of of Superman addressing the issue of
Damien and Jonathan Kim because Superboy
effectively sits down and says okay the
whole reason Tim Drake Came Here is
because some point along the line Damien
you're gonna betray my son and when you
do he's gonna lose his mind and he's
gonna destroy Metropolis so you guys
can't be friends anymore you guys can't
hang out and it's kind of interesting
this is actually a really interesting
scenario this is the Perils of time
travel this is the danger of time travel
we don't have an answer to the question
of if Superman lets them stay friends is
that what leads to the conflict or
Superman refuses to let them stay
friends is that what leads to the
conflict we don't know we don't have an
answer to that we don't know which one
of these paths leads to this massive
Calamity maybe they both do I mean sure
you know an argument can be made well
you know things have changed just by
virtue of Tim Drake going into the past
and you know encountering them and
trying to stop them but it doesn't mean
that it's not going to happen it could
very well just happen by a different
means the circumstance could unfold in a
similar way just under something a
little bit different you know different
conditions but the whole event remains
maybe it's Gotham City that Jonathan
blows up instead of metropolis that's
the cool thing about this and that's why
this is interesting because it does
leave the question out there has the
entire conflict been prevented now
before his defense here Damien steps up
and this is this is a cool thing this is
why Jonathan as a character has such a
great impact on Damien
for those people who have been reading
DC Comics for quite some time really you
know with like a son of the demon going
all the way back to the introduction of
Damian Wayne his characters evolved a
lot over the years when he first showed
up in fact he pissed off a lot of Batman
fans when he first showed up he was just
this really entitled spoiled kid who
believed the world revolved around him
it was his way or the wrong way and
that's really how his character was
initially now over the years as
different writers have evolved his
character he's grown the way that you
would expect him to a lot of this has
been a byproduct of Batman stepping in
and Batman basically saying look our job
is to protect people our job is not to
kill people who do bad things that's the
easy way out I mean there's been a lot
of work that's been done on behalf of
like Batman's character to kind of flesh
out Damien Wayne but in terms of like
him being more of a brighter spot him
kind of growing up and realizing he's
not the center of the universe a lot of
that comes from Jonathan Kent because
Jonathan Kent's kind of like this
immutable force of happiness that exists
that's why I love his character so much
because he's just a funny character to
read about and so that's why him and
Damien Wayne get along so well because
it's almost like yin and yang it's all
it's like oil and vinegar it's light and
dark it's just cool thing were these two
characters who you would never expect to
be friends just immediately hit it off
and they have an amazing friendship but
in a lot of ways whether Damien realizes
it or not Jonathan Kent helps to impact
him and make him a better person the
other half of this is remember despite
the fact that Damian Wayne does have a
checkered past and even though he does
you know has done some pretty shady
things he is an honorable guy and so in
his mind it is basically look Jonathan's
not just a potential member of the Teen
Titans he's not just a person that I've
gone on adventures with he's a friend
and where I come from Friends watch
their friends backs that's very
important that's a very significant
thing when it comes to his character
because it really hits the evolution of
Damian Wayne as he's grown over the
years and so that's why it's so cool so
what they end up doing is basically
calling a vote and it's actually really
funny because they're teleported to the
Justice League Watchtower by Superman
and like their initial response is like
dude we're in the Justice League
Watchtower man like
it's really funny like they're sitting
down at like the big superheroes chairs
and it's funny because it's like man
like we're dude we get to sit at the
adult table
it's really really interesting and it's
really intriguing because this again
hits home with the idea that they're
teenagers they're having fun you know
it's it's what's so cool about that is
that's why I love the Teen Titans so
much now of course Damien's response is
okay we basically got to call this to a
vote and Damien's on the corner of
Jonathan Ken he's like look let's make
him a partial Titan at the very least
now even if it's only one of those
circumstances where Damian's like look
we got to keep an eye on Jonathan Kent
just to make sure he doesn't lose his
mind it is cool because he is basically
voting for Jonathan to be rolled in when
Damien was staunchly against it
initially his whole stance was you're
not a teenager you're a preteen you're
not old enough to be on the Teen Titans
now of course this also sees the arrival
of Batman you know after having uh come
to you more or less after being defeated
by by Tim Drake kind of knocked
unconscious and he basically says okay
let's take a vote and the result is that
you know everybody's kind of like no
we're not really in favor of Jonathan
can't joining the Teen Titans now it's
not because they hate Jonathan right I
mean there may be a little bit of fear
there may be a little bit of concerned
but the bigger idea here is that when
Tim Drake showed up Tim Drake dismantled
the the Teen Titans so fast and so
easily now keep in mind Batman
Incorporated way back before the new 52
I guess really it was Batman
Incorporated when new 52 was launched
that basically confirmed that Tim Drake
is probably the world's best detective
second only to Bruce Wayne that he's
Beyond yo Damian Wayne he's Beyond Dick
Grayson he's Beyond uh Jason Todd in
terms of his detective abilities he's
just below Bruce Wayne and so it's not
like they went against the Joker and the
Joker just dismantled them you know
where the Riddler Who tricked them you
know it's one of the the best detectives
out there who knows all their strengths
and weaknesses because he came from the
future but it is cool because what this
means is that the Teen Titans were
effectively fighting a villain that
could predict all their moves before
they made them and so in order to
basically be that much better they have
to be quote unquote unpredictable which
is to say they have to have a better
understanding of each other they have to
know what all their strengths and
weaknesses are now this is not
accidental or it's not like DC put this
in there just for the sake of just
having it in there way back in in when
the Justice League was first law dollars
back in 1960 one of the first things the
Justice League did in order to instill
trust in each member of the team was to
reveal their identities to each other
they're basically saying like here's
here's our secret identities you know
ibrews I Batman and Bruce Wayne you know
I Superman and Clark Kent I Wonder Woman
am Diana Prince I The Flash and Barry
Allen it was cool to see that kind of
thing because it instilled trust now
this is why this is done it's a homage
to the old school Justice League story
but it's designed to hit home with the
idea that the only way to really know
someone is to let your guard down is to
basically say okay all my cards are on
the table I'm not holding anything back
they might accept you they might reject
you but you have no regrets under the
circumstances and that's where the Teen
Titans have to do they gotta throw their
cards out there they gotta just spill
out their strengths their weaknesses
their fears their hopes and desires and
make themselves stronger as a team so
that instead of viewing each other as
just people who fight alongside other
people they view themselves as a family
that they're invested in each other
because they find a common connectivity
they find a common theme something that
unites them under a singular banner and
until they're able to do that on their
own there's no room for new additions
and so the result is that John Jonathan
Kent is basically sit on the sidelines
and he's effectively not allowed into
the Teen Titans so again that's really
how this this epilogue ends and it's a
great it's a great epilogue to this
whole thing I love this story it's a
great little follow-up great little
aftermath but if you guys are new here
to Comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
peace